the creepy cuomo fallout keeps getting
worse for new york's disgraced governor
he could now face criminal charges
multiple
das in the state are launching
investigations into cuomo's actions
who's accused of sexually harassing 11
women
cuomo is defiant as ever despite
mounting pressure from democrats to step
aside
i think he should resign i'm sure there
are some embraces that were totally
innocent
but apparently the attorney general
decided there were things that weren't
i continue to believe the governor
should resign you absolutely should
resign
the fact that there are 11 women coming
forward
is deeply deeply disturbing i do believe
he should resign
and what about q-tip loving chris cuomo
the cnn anchor completely ignored the
massive scandal last night on his show
that's after the new york ag said chris
got quote confidential state
intel and helped write a response to one
of his brother's accusers greg yesterday
you brought up ralph
northam as everybody knows how the
blackface scandal and right everybody
called on him to resign even democrats
and he didn't do it and now he's still
sitting in the governor's office
i think this is i think this is
different because he's got the hard left
after i mean he's he's like king kong
right now in the build
at the top of the building swatting at
the planes still clutching a woman
uh he's i i don't think he's gonna last
uh but i go back to what geraldo said i
mean who replaces him
um the people i mean we might be going
from the outer circle of hell to the
inner circle of hell
if we get leticia james or de blasio i
mean imagine
these are people that have no compassion
about victims of crime so we have
we want him to hold on i don't no i want
no he's got to go i mean 11 women
and i mean this i mean we should just
sit back and let the process take care
of it
i'm just chris cuomo is just really
lucky that he doesn't have to ever cover
big ugly stories right he could play
with the q-tip but he can't talk about
the nursing homes you know
uh he can talk about how his bro is
single and ready to mingle
but he can't talk about his brother's
crimes with women it's it's like oddly
convenient
i would say that cnn could have they
should have him on as a guest
cnn should have chris cuomo on as a
guest therefore he doesn't run the
segment and they could ask him questions
i should create a conflict of interest
with regards to january 6th
so i just never have to talk about it
i'm sorry i have a conflict can't talk
about it
um dana perino from a public relations
standpoint
please give chris not chris please give
governor cuomo a grade on how he's done
thus far i would say f if you was for
integrity
but you got to say like he's just
basically going to hold on and it's
going to be
godzilla gorilla king kong king kong
godzilla the other one
king kong um you know there's it's a
possibility that
they just drag he drags this thing out
as long as he can he doesn't care
that he doesn't have a friend in the
world he doesn't care that it's
obvious like one of the things he did i
think is so egregious is changing the
rules
so that that state trooper that he had
his eyes on would then be added to his
detail
and then he harassed her in front of
everybody and her boss did nothing about
it
while he was doing that i think that's
one of the most egregious things she's
one of the 11.
and she didn't want to come forward but
she did because she thought it would be
the right thing to do so
everyone else is doing the right thing
and he's doing the wrong thing so he
doesn't care if he doesn't have
a friend in the world the other thing
that's different with northam is that
governor northam apologized
right and then powered through this guy
is just a complete
jerk and i don't think it's a great idea
to keep showing that you know we keep
showing like the video he put out
of how he just kisses everybody and
everything's fine it's like no big deal
like no
there it is like yeah i i don't think
that that's the right thing to do
although you know
maybe from a pr perspective maybe it was
smart they put out this video and they
then we just keep playing it
he always looks like he's trying to suck
a pimple oh that's disgusting
pimple doctor all right geraldo if this
moves forward with impeachment
how long is a process like that going to
impeachment is his big peril but i have
to say
andrew cuomo is no harvey weinstein when
you look at these
charges look at them look at them
feeling that's a little bit
disgusting and disgraceful and uh you
know what makes me puke and this guy is
you know he didn't rape anybody i mean i
i just want to say
that it is interesting to me that
everyone has seized on these sexual
assaults
and nobody mentions the nursing home
nobody mentions these
hundreds and hundreds of people who died
arguably because of
executive decisions made in albany
nobody talks about they have a press
conference there we lost 15 000 people
they got two reporters show up
uh sexual assault they got 300
jumping all over each other ask oh did
he put his hand on her elbow
did he uh you know smooth his his
mustard well he doesn't have a mustache
but
i i just think that katie it is it is a
good point that this scandal is more
devastating politically
than the other scandal where people died
as a result and he hid data
to cover it up yeah right yeah and with
that there was kind of this
people being engaged together so the new
jersey governor
made some of the same decisions the
democratic governor in
michigan made some of the same decisions
so they all kind of wanted some
immunity from the justice department
which apparently they were happy to give
them
but on the resignation of andrew or
andrew cuomo i don't know if he'll
resign i don't think he will think he's
going to stay
and this is all on democrats to hold him
accountable they're in charge and
if they really want to put their money
where their mouth is when it comes to me
too
and women's rights and sexual harassment
in the workplace they would impeach him
now the white house
president biden said yesterday that he
should resign but when they were pressed
again today about whether he should be
impeached because he's looking like he's
not going to resign
they won't go as far as saying that
democrats should act to
impeach him and then an interesting and
ironic and awful terrible thing
based on the nursing home issue today is
jen saki was asked if he should still be
in a leadership position
on these coveted calls for all of the
democratic governors every week with the
white house
and she said that she doesn't want to
hurt the people of new york by removing
andrew cuomo from a position of
leadership to run the coveted response
not just for new york but for the other
states as if he hasn't done all this
damage including putting thousands of
that's a great
people back into the nursing homes and
so they're kind of using that as a
shield
uh rather than taking responsibility for
it and it's one thing to say he should
resign but it's another to
call for action if he refuses jen's had
a tough week
i'll say it dana won't say it but i'll
say it you've had a tough week jen
next democrats hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else